How do you feel in a space when...
you have to be vulnerable?
'Cause I have issues with vulnerability
and I'm a woman.
I can take that one.
Yeah, that one I got.
I want you both to take it,
so you just start, J.J.
Well, excuse me.
I'll start with that one.
I've realized just being vulnerable
in a character
is easy for me,
because I do it in life,
I'm open and honest, I don't...
You could judge me, it's fine. You know?
I'm okay with that,
because I know who I am. Right?
So, the more honest you are with yourself
about who you are and your flaws,
and what shortcomings, and what not...
being vulnerable is easier.
That's been my experience.
That's amazing.
Because for me, vulnerability is...
is... When I feel vulnerable, I feel weak.
It's like, I cannot be vulnerable,
this is so uncomfortable,
I gotta go out here,
I gotta go somewhere else.
You know, for me, it's always like,
I have to be protected.
I feel most comfortable when I'm strong,
when it's not like,
"I can't tell somebody I need help."
You know what I mean?
Like, me? Hell no.
I do my own thing, I'm independent.
You know?
And at times, if... I'm learning now
that it's okay, at times, to be, like...
"Yes, please."
You know what that is?
That's your ego.
You think it's ego?
Yeah, yeah. It's your ego
trying to protect itself.
Ego isn't a bad word. Ego...
It's like, we all have an ego.
Yes.
It's a matter of having a balanced ego
or a solid ego.
I don't wanna say strong ego, but like--
-A balance. Just... Yeah.
-Yeah.
When you're able
to withdraw from both... Yes.
I have to agree with you. I never thought
about that, that's interesting.
So I challenge myself
whenever I feel, let's say,
when my machismo may kick in and...
let's say, a woman telling me something
about myself,
saying I'm sensitive or something,
I'm like, "I ain't sensitive. Whatever."
And then I check, I go,
"No, no, no. Let's check in.
Let's check in. Maybe she's right.
Maybe you are coming from a place
of this and that."
And I'll make sure that I'll address it,
'cause I wanna understand.
Right? I seek understanding.
And then, let's say she's right,
I'm like, "You know what? You were right.
That's me... That was triggered
by some part of me that..."
You know, I'll be vulnerable and open
about whatever that is.